two reporters in Myanmar who just shared  a Pulitzer Prize are free this morning  after more than a year in jail crowds of  supporters surrounded while alone and  Cha so you when they were released they  were convicted of illegally possessing  official documents and sentenced to  seven years in prison last September the  reporters from the Reuters news agency  say they were framed and did not break  any laws they were investigating the  killings of row hanga Muslims in Myanmar  once known as Burma when they were  arrested in 2017 lawn and so you were  freed in a general amnesty of thousands  of prisoners Myanmar's governor's  government pardon me says the release  who did the long term interest of the  country